This episode is sponsored by state form.
[Inaudible].
From scare. Jordan comes as follow up to the creepiest bodies.
What movies since nine lives. Oh, Madison,
I've been a bag cutie in the smash hit packed with enough social
commentary to trick snobs into watching more B-movie scifi horror flags
only watch for the complex racial allegories.
That's uh, the Dred Scott decision,
Uh,
enter the twisted nightmare of having to spend time in the woods with your lame
parents don't need the internet.
You've got the outer net plus your dad's crappy work friends.
What do we say? I hate you.
And some ashy relatives your mom never told you about in a
film that black people can finally point to and say,
hanging out with family sucks for us too. You know.
[Inaudible].
Experienced powerhouse dual performances by great actors unleashing their full
range of crazy faces
Anchored by Lapita.
[inaudible] making a futile attempt to not look like a goddess who puts other
actors to shame with her left tear, duct alone
and Winston Duke,
a man with truly frightening levels of BD E Hey,
big dad, energy. I'm just.
Gonna watch the giants highlights. Okay.
You know, in any other horror movie, he'd be the dumb jock who dies first.
The Sackler and everything.
See what a real messed up family looks like with the arrival of the
tethered Dabo gangers with matching gold scissors,
special offhand gestures
And venture brothers speed suits. I look like Santa magic. Janitor.
They're part of a subterranean quote army who walk like Sims
Talk like they spent the night doing Slayer karaoke, this
And go down like a bunch of pongs.
[Inaudible].
What's so scary about yourself trying to kill you. No one sucks more than me
Follow Jordan Peele on his evolution into the modern day Hitchcock who
crafts deeply unsettling,
then dumps exposition on you in the final act like the last scene of psycho.
He was simply doing everything possible to keep alive the illusion of his
mother.
Because while the tethered were scarily effective as an allegory,
the explanation that they're actually an underground experiment,
raises a few questions. Why is there a tethered for everyone in America?
How is there enough space underground for them?
How many people must have known about these experiments?
How to know and find out in the last 30 years,
surely they were using enough electricity,
water in raw materials to raise some red flags.
Can the tiller control the records independently or not? If not,
how are they executing his complicated plan? If so,
why did they bother staying on the ground?
Did the people who make the teller forget to lock the door on the way out?
How do they have the same body type as, or double? Their diet is 107th Avenue.
The, to make the rabbits, but with the remedy where they get thousands,
if not millions of red jumpsuits and scissors, every buckwheat, everything,
this monitor got silly,
just like planters and always what a political party buildings,
vertical differences are. They just piles of Goodman tunnels.
But notice what you're telling me,
Charlotte's on a country border and it keeps plugging the wall, even character.
Whereas your parents it's going to courts. We die. It's
[inaudible] so grab your buddies to take the ultimate horror Rorschach test
where you'll see a bunny and think, ah,
clever nod to the black photo traditional Br'er rabbit, or, huh,
wouldn't be a must have really hated his toy story. Four character.
Infinity and your mom.
Or you know what? Sometimes the rabbit is just a rabbit.
Now get your head out of your and go back to the stabby. Stabby. You understand
say story bombs.
Kannada Zora Neale, hurtin, thigh master
spaghetti. L'Oreal because you're worth it.
Attack of the clones
Based on how frequently they appear in movies.
You think people are walking through halls. Amir's like every day,
this episode is sponsored by state farm.
Like a good neighbor state farm is there.
Your mother was no Sharon Stone.
Red is so if it's too loud,
your two old delusions.